[Música]
a quien no le ha dolido la vida
quien no ha tenido una excepción amorosa
de esas de las que crees que jamás vas a
poder levantarte
quien no ha tenido una muerte cercana un
accidente
el 15 de agosto del 2000 mi vida y la
vida de mi familia ha cambiado por
completo
durante toda la noche hubo una fuga de
gas
la mañana muy temprano mi papá salió a
trabajar
mi hermana y yo nos despertamos
bajamos mi caso era de dos pisos
comenzamos a hacer los de desayunar
y con ese ruido despertamos a mi mamá
y sabes las normas siempre tienen un
sexto sentido y saben cuando algo pasa
y se levanta mi mamá con esta sensación
comienza a bajar las escaleras de la
casa y escucha y huele el gas en toda la
casa
sabe que lo que sigue es que la casa va
a explotar por puro instinto básico el
olfato y se da cuenta que la fuga
proviene del cuarto de servicio donde
está la persona que nos apoya comienza a
tocar ya gritar su nombre mi hermana y
yo siguiendo a mi mamá sin saber que
estaba pasando no respondía la persona
de servicio señal que por la cantidad de
gas se había desmayado
mi mamá sale de la casa corriendo
buscando ayuda y en ese preciso momento
el vecino se está subiendo a sus coches
para irse a trabajar
le dice lo que está pasando y el vecino
le dice que no se preocupe que él vendrá
no va a cerrar la fuga y que nos saque y
mamá nos toma de la mano nos pone en el
marco de la puerta principal y la
explosión se da por tres cosas el
oxígeno de abrir la puerta el gas
acumulado y las estufas de antes en el
2000 tenían un piloto prendido esas tres
cosas generan la explosión y lo que hace
el fuego es buscar salida y la salida
estaba en las puertas en las ventanas no
pasan ni 23 segundos cuando están todos
los vecinos afuera con las mangueras con
las que regamos nuestras plantas
nuestras flores nuestros árboles el 15
de agosto del 2000 nos apagaron el fuego
completo del cuerpo había que avisarle a
mi papá una vez que ya no estábamos en
llamas mi mamá le pide a la vez sin
entrar a su casa
y de la temperatura tan alta que había
adquirido la piel va dejando las huellas
de los pies en la alfombra de la vecina
levanta el teléfono le avisa mi papá lo
que está pasando le dice mi papá que va
para allá y mi mamá siente la necesidad
de acostarse ya se dio cuenta que dejó
las huellas de los pies marcados y
entonces se acuesta en el piso de la
cocina de la vecina que generalmente es
un piso de cerámica fría
se acuesta y me acuesto enseguida y por
primera vez a los 8 años me planteo la
posibilidad de morir
y le pregunto muy segura que si nos
vamos a morir y también me contesta muy
segura que no que nos van a poner mucha
goma y que vamos a estar bien llegan las
ambulancias los bomberos y nos trasladan
al primer hospital en este primer
hospital está un equipo de doctores nos
meten en una primera operación que
aunque lo voy a decir de manera muy
gorda como con una lija quitar toda la
piel muerte nos dejan en vil vida una
vez saliendo de esta operación le dicen
a mi papá
tienes que irte de chihuahua
tu hija la mayor se está muriendo tienes
que irte en ese mismo instante otro
doctor interrumpe y dice no ni para que
te las llevas ni ella ni tu esposa
ni tu otra hija van a sobrevivir
mi papá en ese momento hace una junta
con los doctores y comienzan a decidir
cuál sería la mejor opción para movernos
entre varias opciones decían que la
mejor es un hospital que stern a las y
nos traslada
llegamos a este primer hospital y nos
inducen a un coma y durante dos meses y
medio estuvimos completamente dormidas
quien tomaba todas las decisiones era mi
papá quien firmaba cada consentimiento
en cada operación de que podíamos perder
la vida era él
en esta etapa mi papá se da cuenta de la
realidad que vive y se da cuenta que el
tema de las quemaduras no se va a acabar
en dos o tres semanas y comienza a
investigar para darse cuenta dónde está
parado podías ver a un hombre de 30 años
leer revistas realidades para investigar
qué cremas qué tratamientos donde
estaban las mejores opciones de
reconstrucción y en esa investigación se
da cuenta que hay un gran hospital en
otra parte de eeuu pero había un
problema solamente aceptaban niños
nos traslada este hospital a mi hermana
en mí y estuvimos divididas y separadas
de mi mamá por un mes obviamente nunca
nos dimos cuenta porque seguíamos
dormidas hasta el momento en que íbamos
a despertar
y nos tenían que explicar dónde
estábamos que había pasado
todo lo que íbamos a pasar después el
proceso de las cirugías de
reconstrucción el proceso de aprender a
hacer todo de nuevo y tenían que
explicarme que había perdido tres dedos
de la mano derecha
cuando ocurrió hace un momento al
despertar cuando mi papá me explica todo
esto lo único que sale de mi boca es
decir que sigue que tengo que hacer
comenzamos un proceso de recuperación
con mucho dolor como si la unidad nos
hubiera puesto pausa y no se hubiera
podido darnos la oportunidad de empezar
de nuevo
aprender a caminar de nuevo llevarnos
una cuchara a la boca
aprender a vestirnos aprender a
sentarnos a pararnos pero todo sumado de
un dolor físico profundo
cuando pudimos pasar esta etapa de
recuperación regresamos a chihuahua y en
un principio tengo que confesar que fue
un poco fácil el hecho de ser niña y
haber pasado por la adversidad no te da
mucha visión de lo que está pasando ni
de lo que viene y entonces solamente
vives el presente y vives ese momento
pero eso no iba a durar toda la vida
y cuando llegaron los 11 y los 12 años a
mi vida
entonces entendí que me había pasado
y entendí que estas cicatrices que este
cuerpo que ahora
era distinto me iba a acompañar siempre
y a los 12 años empecé a entender que al
lugar al que yo llegaba el supermercado
el cine en la escuela la farmacia
contrastada
en todos los lugares había miradas y eso
provocaba ciertas cosas
que me recomendaban cosas a veces que me
preguntaran incluso cuchicheos gente que
solamente hablaba entre ellos pero yo
sabía que estaban hablando de las
quemaduras
y a los 11 y 12 años no fue nada grato
esa parte de mi vida
así que con esa misma fortaleza con la
que dije que sigue y con esa misma
fortaleza con la que aprendí a caminar
de nuevo con dolor a los 12 años me tape
el cuerpo entero
y le dije a mis papás que el uniforme de
la escuela lo quería de manga larga que
no quería calcetas que querían mallas y
que de ahora en adelante nadie se iba a
enterar que estaba quemado
y durante seis años consecutivos de mi
vida escondí esta cicatriz y durante
seis años consecutivos de mi vida sufría
por las mismas cosas cada albercada cada
fiesta donde tenía que llevar un vestido
corto
cada puesta en el teatro porque a mí me
encantaba bailar entonces cada vestuario
significaba que la gente me iba a
reconocer con ciertas cicatrices seis
años sufriendo por las mismas cosas
hasta aquí llegó un momento en mi vida
que entendí que estas cicatrices me van
a acompañar por el resto de mi vida
y tenía dos opciones muy claras o seguía
sufriendo y tapando me y además
muriéndome de calor porque vivía en el
desierto y amaba estas cicatrices y
aceptaba esta realidad que me va a
acompañar toda la vida
y en mi caso es muy claro porque las
cicatrices se notan pero en el caso de
los que estamos acá presente están las
que se notan pero también las que no se
notan
en la vida todos pasamos por momentos
complejos todos pasamos por momentos
profundamente dolorosos
pero esos momentos son donde están las
mayores lecciones de nuestra vida no hay
vuelta atrás y agradezco este evento en
mi vida porque nunca me había conocido
tan fuerte tan valiente
tan agradecido
y nunca había conocido mi misión hasta
que viví este accidente
mi propuesta el día de hoy es abracemos
nuestra cicatriz que nuestras cicatrices
no nos detengan que sean el combustible
perfecto para seguir avanzando que sean
la parte fundamental de nuestra vida que
nos da la sabiduría para continuar en
nuestro camino que no se nos olviden que
estos momentos dolorosos nos han
enseñado porque estoy muy segura que
todos los que están acá y todos los que
van a ver este vídeo
encuentran en esos momentos del pasado o
que están viviendo grandes lecciones y
adicional a las lecciones grandes
ventajas siempre todo lo que nos pasa en
nuestra vida nos otorga también
beneficios y les voy a contar uno de
ellos yo para venir a esta plática y
también una gira soy mamá de dos bebés
uno de tres años y uno de uno entonces
siempre ando muy corta de tiempo siempre
se me olvidan las cosas aún cuando tengo
agenda así que antes de venirme quería
pintar las uñas llegué a una estética y
no necesita entonces llegué y les
pregunté si tenía un espacio voltea la
chica del mostrador a ver la agenda a
ver el reloj y me dice no tengo espacio
porque en 20 minutos llega la persona
que hizo cita como reclamando me que
necesita
y le digo no importa porque solo tengo
siete dedos entonces yo creo que si me
acabas
y le dijo está bien pasa entonces me
pinto las uñas
adicional a eso mi casa es de dos pisos
y no sé si te ha pasado cuando ya estás
en tu cama agusto rico y de repente te
hacen y hay que bajar por el agua yo por
ejemplo volteo con mi marido y le digo
amor me traes agua y me dice
y yo le digo estoy quemada
no sé creando
lo que sí es real que yo viajo mucho por
lo que hago por los talleres por las
conferencias y siempre tengo un outfit
que me llegó al aeropuerto blusa de
manga corta que se nota en las
cicatrices un suéter porque siempre hace
frío y donde haya que hacer fila y
amiguitos de pie y paso rápido
con lo que quiero decir es observar las
ventajas del dolor
veamos de otra cara al dolor porque la
tiene la parte triste dolorosa lo que no
está algo que nos falta ya lo sabemos
ahora miremos y ampliemos esa visión de
túnel que tenemos para lo que no hay lo
que falta lo que se fue ampliamos esa
misión esa visión de túnel para lo que
hacía
las bendiciones que están presentes para
las lecciones que hemos aprendido
abracemos estas cicatrices que hacen que
nuestra vida contraste que hacen que
nuestra vida sea una historia digna de
ser contada
[Aplausos]
[Música]